all right if you're looking for a way to
give back this holiday season the
catholic charities of southern nevada
needs your help
feeding the community especially our
seniors here's more information on their
food and nutrition services
i'm excited to talk about catholic
charities of southern nevada first and
foremost
just introduce us to the organization
we've been in uh business since 1941 so
we're about ready to approach our 80th
anniversary there aren't too many things
that are 80 years old in southern nevada
congratulations
we help thousands of people every day uh
we'll talk about some of the food
programs that are a staple
for the agency but we also handle
shelter operations and
adoption services lots of great ways to
help people that
have needs in our community beautiful
and i know you mentioned the food and
nutrition so how are you guys helping
people during the holidays i know that's
a part of the program
there are really three legs to the to
the chair
of our food program uh one that is a big
one is meals on wheels
so we help over 2 400 seniors
every day with meals on wheels and
that's
food that goes directly out from our
kitchens with our drivers and
refrigerated trucks
to the client directly and they get
seven meals at a time
during the pandemic we've had to leave
the meal at the door and call the client
to make sure that they get it
and then do a smile or a wave to the
client
we also provide pet food for people that
have pets so that they're not sharing
their food with their pets so
there's great needs there's still a
waiting list for meals on wheels
due to funding challenges so that's a
big program that helps
thousands of our seniors and that
program is growing this thanksgiving
will give out three thousand
turkeys and the fixins to all of our
needy clients
uh because of the pandemic we're having
to create social distancing
uh and try to keep that product safe as
it goes across the table to the clients
how people can donate uh funds or gift
cards to us to help us pay for that
product
uh because you might imagine the need
for food
during the pandemic is greater than it's
ever been absolutely and how does the
meals on wheels program actually work
how can people get involved or
apply to be a part of it you can go on
the website as well
and uh apply for the program uh the all
the information the contact information
the phone numbers to apply for meals on
wheels basically if you're 60 years old
and
and are in need of food and have limited
mobility
uh unfortunately now you have to go on
the waiting list because
funding is tight that program as people
in southern nevada
come here to rely locate and retire and
age in place
that need goes up any encouraging words
beacon time for everybody during this
time
this is an unprecedented year of
challenge but i also
think it's a time for us to be grateful
for our blessings uh
with those of us that have been able to
stay healthy or recover
uh and those of us that have been able
to continue to be innovative
to serve we have served every single day
at catholic charities despite the
pandemic
so that gives me hope to know that there
is an end in sight but until there is
uh let's stay hopeful and grateful for
our blessings and remember that
despite our challenges there are people
less fortunate than all of us
and when we give of ourselves or makes
more room in our heart for gratitude
great words by deacon tom thank you for
joining us catholic charities
of southern nevada is located at 1501
las vegas boulevard north you can call
that number right there on your screen
or simply visit catholiccharities.com to
donate
and learn more